the head of Russia's Wagner group has
released his first statement since the
mercenary Fighters Mutiny on June 24th
in an 11-minute audio recording pagosian
said that he took the action because his
group was going to be disbanded he added
the Belarusian President Alexander
lukashenko offered a solution for Wagner
to continue working legally in Russia he
also compared his march on Moscow to
Russia's invasion of Ukraine saying that
troops of Wagner's level could have
completed Russia's special military
operation in 24 hours here are some
highlights of his statement
as a result of intrigue Wagner was bound
to cease to exist on July the 1st the
decision was made at the worst possible
moment despite us showing no aggression
we were hit by a rocket strike and then
by helicopters around 30 Fighters were
killed some were wounded this triggered
the decision to move out immediately
the goal of the March was to prevent the
eradication of Wagner ensuring those who
made a huge amount of mistakes during
the special military operation because
of their incompetence be held
accountable
Daniel Hawkins joins us now live from
Moscow so this Domino has just dropped
we were waiting to hear what if anything
Daniel pregosian would say now he's
released this 11-minute audio statement
what's next for Wagner and its
relationship with the Kremlin
well pogosian has been quite
conspicuously absent uh from the public
eye unusual from man who was so uh used
to seeking the public Limelight up until
just about half an hour ago quite an
extraordinary 11-minute statement from
evgenic progression in which the summary
really is Mutiny what Mutiny he said
that he had no intention to seize power
or change the government in Russia
instead saying that the whole thing the
whole uh incident if you like uh was
simply a demonstration a demonstration
of the weak spots of Russian Security
Forces a demonstration of how according
to him Russia's so-called special
miniature operation in Ukraine could
have gone if given to the hands of the
most professional fighting force in the
world that's how he described his Wagner
group in this statement saying also that
he stopped just in time to prevent
Bloodshed something of course he's said
before and the most mysterious part of
course uh on which questions will be
asked is that Wagner will apparently be
given the opportunity to operate within
some sort of new framework now how
exactly that will look it's hard to say
that Russia's authorities confirmed
progression is still under investigation
for Mutiny initially of course Putin
said the charges will be dropped peskov
seller charges will be dropped now that
seems to be
um on the table once again
um so it's very much hard to say because
of course this comes at a bad time uh
for the uh the Russian military on the
front lines in Ukraine
um a lot will depend on the next few
days as to the kremlin's response to
this statement
um how that relationship will develop if
there will be one at all
Daniel Wagner was one of the most
effective fighting forces in Ukraine
fighting of course on behalf of Russia
how will these events impact the
conflict in Ukraine
well these events come as I say at a
very bad time for the Russian Armed
Forces it's in the middle of the
Ukrainian counter-offensive which has
been of course faltering it's perhaps
not gone as many had expected it to go
but nevertheless Russian troops do find
themselves under a tremendous amount of
pressure both on the zaporosia front on
the Donetsk front as well and Russia
does lose
um it's arguably best most professional
fighting force um the wagon writes are
numbered around 25 000 that's according
to Evgeni progression himself but they
brought Russia some of their biggest you
could say victories including over the
last few weeks uh this is likely to sow
some sort of confusion
um on the front lines among Russian
soldiers and commanders and it's likely
to pull Russian troops away from other
areas as well where back where the
wagonal group was holding those lines
where the Russian army itself had either
retreated or remain static
um it also of course galvanizes the
Ukrainian forces IT projects an image of
weakness of chaos another weak shade of
command which the Ukrainian Army will
try to exploit and that's really a
common theme which both the Russian
authorities have said and which key of
officials have said as well it's a
common theme so this is very much at a
bad time for the Kremlin and for the
Russian forces and no doubt leaves them
in a weaker position than they were just
uh 76 hours ago Daniel Hawkins in Moscow
thank you very much